getting it wrong isn't that bad that's  the other thing when we make mistakes  and we've made doozies like the fire  phone and many other things it just  didn't work out because I could we don't  have enough time for me to list all of  our failed experiments but the big  Winners pay for thousands of field  experiments so you try something like  Prime and it was very expensive at the  beginning it cost us a lot of money  because what happens when you offer a  free all you can eat buffet who shows up  to the buffet first the heavy eaters  it's scary it's like oh my god did I  really say as many prawns as you can eat  and so that is what happened but surely  we could see the trend lines we could  see that you know all kinds of customers  were coming and they appreciated that  service